sept femmes tuées par leur conjoint
depuis le début de l'année au québec
cette famille brisée à jamais en moyenne
au québec 12 femmes qui meurent chaque
année on est déjà rendu à 7 c'est sans
compter les dommages collatéraux avec
les enfants qui se retrouvent orphelins
c'est épouvantable ingrid falaise
ébranlé par cette augmentation de
violences meurtrières exige des actions
et maintenant des paroles on entend
depuis longtemps les fours des actions
concrètes qu est ce que vous mettez en
place concrètement pour vrai vrai vrai
le gouvernement se montre préoccupé par
la situation et promet davantage de
ressources et d'argent et signalements
de violences conjugales ont augmenté de
12% dernièrement il ya plus de
répression qui se fait autour de la
violence conjugale
donc ce c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction dans le sens où c'est
important que les gens comprennent que
cette violence là ne n'est pas impunis
au québec et ne peut pas se faire
impunément
c'est définitivement pas le québec qu'on
veut léguer à nos filles et aux garçons
si ça prend plus de moyens on va mettre
plus de moyens pour les partis
d'opposition
c'est loin d'être suffisant il faut
qu'il y ait une personne au gouvernement
qui soit responsable de regarder ce qui
se passe des gestes clairs que le
premier ministre doit poser en nommant
quelqu'un qui va s'en occuper à temps
plein il ya quand même des impacts de
confinement le convoi appareils martin
métivier gère l'une des cinq cellules de
crise met sur pied au québec pour tenter
de contrer la violence conjugale
depuis le début de l'année le nombre
d'interventions augmenté de 20 % et une
augmentation des situations de violence
mais aussi une augmentation de gravité
des situations de violence qu'on sera
conclue c'est que la violence est plus
importante
puis avec beaucoup plus d'agressions
physiques qu'on voyait auparavant
selon lui il est temps d'augmenter les
ressources sur le terrain les cellules
de crise on a besoin à montréal on a
besoin qu'ils ont de québec on a besoin
un peu partout plusieurs intervenants du
milieu attendent avec impatience le
budget qui sera déposé demain et devant
l'urgence d'agir
la solution se trouve dans les écoles
croit une grue de falaise il faut
éduquer nos enfants nos jeunes hommes
dans les écoles de dès la petite enfance
il faut changer
et nos mentalités ici marie michel
lauzon radio canada montréal